foreign
[Music]
matters which is a program of the north
central stair program that essentially
we help Elevate the stories and share
projects from our farmer Rancher
grantees I am one of the hosts Aaron
Schneider I farm and I work for Sayre
and I am excited to be with you all and
as well as Marie Flanagan our
communication specialist hello hey and
we have a special guest with us today
Peter scold with waxwing farm and he is
here to share
um a story of his farmer Rancher project
which is forcing Belgian and dive and
traviso Radicchio in the Upper Midwest
well yeah I can just give a quick
introduction of myself so I'm Peter
skull from I own waxwing Farm together
with my wife Anna racer
um this coming season will be our 13th
growing season uh growing mixed
vegetables
um both for CSA and we sell probably
half of our businesses selling to
restaurants as well we sell a little bit
to the Prior Lake School District and
outside of the Twin Cities but that's
kind of the the big breakdown and
um yeah we got um through our restaurant
work we got interested in growing
um Radicchio and kind of The Logical
extension of that has brought us to this
project
um so it's just kind of it was a desire
to
expand our options and diversify our
winter offerings to our restaurants and
we thought it might fit the bill but we
needed a little uh help to get over the
hump of of the initial investment in
trial period so the that's why we
applied for the Sarah Grant and once we
got it we put the project into uh into
practice and
um had a few hiccups because of the
coveted pandemic but
um we actually it was It was kind of
nice we we delayed the project or
extended the project by a year because
of that and we were able to put a lot of
stuff that we had learned into practice
and I think the the project was actually
better for it okay so um yeah this is
just a little presentation I put
together just to kind of
um hit the high points of of what we
learned
um so as you can see it the whole thing
was about diversifying our season
extension you know Season extension in
the Upper Midwest is really critical for
Vegetable Farms
um and so
um we just wanted to explore an option
to give us something
um something a little bit more higher
value than some of the root crops
especially for us uh selling to
restaurants you know root crops at
smaller restaurant volumes are not super
profitable
um so having something that
um is a higher demand higher value
product
um was was something that we've been
pursuing for our winter restaurant sales
and we thought that these forcing
chicorys
um would fit that bill pretty well so so
what is a forcing chicory it's um
chicories are a crop that grows a lot
like lettuce so it's got a leafy top
above ground and a single Taproot down
below
it's been used for thousands and
thousands of years it's originally from
the Mediterranean area
um and it includes you know forage crops
and also crops for human consumption
humans and animals alike both the leaves
and The Roots the Roots historically
have been used as a coffee substitute
um so it's it's a crop that is well
known
um in certain parts of the world
um and then Radicchio and Endive are the
things that are the crops in the family
that uh most
um people are familiar with
um and so forcing chicories are a
certain variety that you plant them in
this in the ground and you grow them
like a regular chicory throughout the
growing season but then you dig them up
and you bring them inside and you force
them to grow inside a dark
room or chamber
um which forces them to grow without
chlorophyll and so you get a totally
different product than what grows in the
field
so not only is it is it a unique
um kind of value-added product for that
reason
um but it also it tastes great too it
tastes a lot different than what you
grow in the field so yeah this uh just
kind of gets at why we wanted to to grow
these things again like I mentioned it's
about extending our season our growing
season and finding a way to increase the
value of some of our winter sales to
restaurants in particular
um it worked really well with our our
farm infrastructure because we're able
to use a walk-in cooler as our forcing
chamber that is not used in the winter
and then it also just kind of gives us a
little bit more work to do in the winter
which in theory could take away some of
the workload from the summer
and it's it's all about diversifying
those winter sails so growing the stuff
is uh it's a lot like growing lettuce
um it doesn't really if you're set up to
grow lettuce it doesn't require any
additional equipment
um you can either direct seed it in the
field or transplant it
um the most the biggest difference there
is uh the impact on root shape so this
crop even though a lot of people think
of
chicories as
um a leafy crop
when you're growing them for forcing you
really got to think about it as uh
you're growing a root crop
um and so
um I'll get to it later in the
presentation about why root shape can in
certain situations make a difference but
um once you see them and get them in the
field uh it's just like I said it's just
like growing lettuce so you've got to
keep them weeded keep them well watered
it's a long crop so they have to be
seated
um
right around mid-summer or early July
in order to get them in the ground and
have them grow enough to produce a
sizable root that can be forced
um so for Harvest once you've once
you've grown them all up we used an
undercutter bar to lift the bed and then
pull the roots out just like we would if
we were growing carrots
um you trim the greens and you have to
make sure that you leave the growing tip
intact you can see on the picture on the
left a lot of those roots have about one
to two inches of green still left on top
that's critical for getting especially
for Endive for getting the right shape
um of the final product
um on the right you can see we threw
them into feed sacks that we stored in
our walk-in cooler to help keep them at
the right humidity
and they store just like any other root
crop best at about you know 32 35 with
really high relative humidity
uh here's a picture of the forcing
chamber so like I said the forcing
chamber is uh we utilize an uh walking
cooler that we use in the summer for
um you know storing cold sensitive
things like tomatoes and eggplant and
zucchini and cucumbers but in the winter
that infrastructure was idle so this was
uh this project was a really good way to
utilize that idle space that was
otherwise just sitting there
um we had these galvanized steel tanks
custom made for this project and you can
see kind of just those red hoses
connecting each of the tanks so that we
can circulate water
through the entire system
I think that's helpful to keep the water
aerated and keep keep things healthy but
I don't think it's critical I think you
could
um get by with a much simpler system of
just some tupperwares with roots in them
and you know a couple inches of water
that maybe you changed every couple of
you know maybe once a week or something
like that
um so it certainly doesn't have to be
this sophisticated I think that um
we just wanted to to really have a
system that
um
fit the best like larger scale
commercial systems that we could
identify and so a lot of the larger
commercial systems had had the same kind
of water bath circulating water
um but I don't think it's critical
so this is the actual process for
forcing them for targivo Radicchio you
dig them up uh from the field and you
pull them out of storage and on the left
you can see that these plants were
transplanted so you can see that the
roots are a lot more kind of splayed out
and gnarly
um we trim off most of the greens so on
the left you see the root with a lot of
the greens attached still and then on
the right is what it looks like before
we put it into the bulb crate for
forcing and then on the right hand side
you can see a bulb crate that's ready to
go into the forcing chamber so you peel
off most of the greens
because the green leaves eventually
Decay and die and become kind of a slimy
mess and so the less of that that you
bring into the you know
into the forcing chamber the less
cleanup you have to do on the back side
and then once you put them into the
forcing chamber it takes about three
weeks for them to grow you can see these
ones in this picture we trimmed all the
greens off
um so there's no decaying matter and
that actually worked pretty well too so
um but once they're in there you just
have to make sure that the water level
is sufficient so that the roots have
something to drink
and that you don't accidentally leave
the light on that's the biggest thing is
any light will cause the plants to start
photosynthesizing which degrades them
for Harvest
um you take the bulb crates out
trim off the root and you can see in the
picture you leave kind of a little
little stub of the root that's at least
the traditional Italian way to do it
um uh and you clean off all the bad
leaves and then soak it in cold water to
kind of let it rehydrate just a little
bit it does tend to get a little dried
out in the forcing chamber
and then once you rinse it clean you can
shake it dry and package it
um for sale and just keep it dark so it
doesn't start photosynthesizing so
Endive is a little bit different
um
you can just trim them in the field and
you want to make sure like I said before
you leave the right amount of greens
intact on the left picture on the left
you can see the root on the bottom was
trimmed too close and you can see that
there's five or six small little Sprouts
that are coming off of the sides so
those aren't going to be marketable
because they're going to stay really
really small
um
whereas the root on the top was trimmed
properly and you can still see the
growth tip of the greens intact so
that's going to form a nice tight head
growing from the middle of that root so
that's that's the critical thing that we
learned and that was one of those things
that we didn't learn that lesson the
first year that we did it and so
extending the project by a second year
um allowed us to kind of learn from that
mistake and and have a lot more success
the second year
um Endive is is
grown more on a commercial scale so it's
more of a familiar crop than the forcing
radicchios and so it's been bred to
develop that really nice straight
Tap Root so if you direct seed to
Belgian endive it'll grow a nice
straight Taproot that then could be
packed really tightly into the bulk
crates you can see on the picture on the
right that we fit you know more than
double the number of hand dive Roots
into one bulb crate so it's a much more
efficient use of space
so then harvesting
um and dive grows a little bit slower it
takes more closer to six weeks
um you can see here this picture we've
got on the top there's some chickens
that are just about ready to be
harvested and underneath we have a
um some roots that were started a couple
weeks after that so they're just
starting to grow
so it's but it's basically you can just
cut them off of the um the root either
with a knife or just by snapping them
off trim off any leaves that are you
know ill ill-shaped or have any kind of
tinge of green to them and then you can
pack them right from the forcing crate
um for sale and again keep them dark so
they don't start photosynthesizing we
did notice that the the end I was more
likely to start photosynthesizing than
the Radicchio if you aren't careful
um marketing you know the restaurants
were our primary customers for this uh
product they're both definitely
Specialty Products
um the tardivo is not commercially
available anywhere in the US that we
were available so
um that helped it command a higher price
but also because it's less familiar you
know the the market options are are more
limited for sure specialty restaurants
that either have an open mind or are
have previously worked with it are the
easiest targets Belgian endive on the
other hand
um
is historically more of a large-scale
production it's more of an industrial
crop so it's it's available from regular
wholesalers vegetable wholesalers uh it
shows up on a lot of winter restaurant
Market or restaurant menus
um so because of that reason the market
price is a lot lower so you need to sell
in a higher volume in order to make the
make it work cost wise
I think the opportunity is definitely
there for that but
um it's I think you would have to do it
on a pretty significant volume
other options are winters farmers
markets you know in the same way that uh
for restaurants it's a really unique
different crop to differentiate
ourselves from the competition in the
winter you know if there's a winter
Farmers Market you know just having
these things on your stall is gonna
just everyone's gonna come and take at
least take a look
so then you can tell the story
um
and you know you have to do a lot of
customer education I think but um
the opportunity certainly is there to
get people to at least try this unique
product
and then you know if they're specialty
grocery stores I don't think that
necessarily either of these products are
going to show up in
regular everyday grocery stores but um
there's certainly a possibility for
um customers regular you know individual
customers who either already know about
these
um products or are interested in getting
their hands on something unique and
different so there's other Radicchio
varieties that are either meant to be
forcing varieties like this isantina in
the middle is grows really really small
and it's got a really vibrant cool color
but
um is you know the market for that is
probably pretty limited we've been
growing The Chicory Rosa on the left
um that is not specifically a forcing
variety but in the Upper Midwest it it
works that way
um so we've we've had some success
growing that crap as a forcing Radicchio
and then like I mentioned
um you know the
the Belgian endive I think for our scale
we found that um
the the forcing radicchios are more cost
effective for us just because of the
higher price that they uh command
um but again if you wanted to really
scale up and do an acre or two of
Belgian endive and you know talk to a
wholesaler and try to kind of corner the
the market
um I think that there's possibility
there and I think that you know that it
could be cost effective so I think
there's definitely opportunities that
have been illuminated by this this uh
project yeah and so I mean couldn't have
done it without North Central Sarah so
uh just thank you for everything that
um
the organization has done to support and
fund this project it was it was a lot of
fun and we learned a lot and we
certainly developed a practice that
we're going to keep using so uh overall
it's been a huge success what just like
so for someone experiencing Radicchio or
Endive for the first time how would you
describe that taste or like yeah it's um
it's definitely bitter so you know I
think
um that's the the first thing that um
turns people off is that it's it's got a
bitterness to it
um you know because we work with the
restaurants we've been
they've been slowly nudging us to
growing a lot of radicchios a lot of
restaurants are are really excited about
that so you know there's kind of a
spectrum of like the regular main season
um ridicuous like with um kind of frize
and
um
oh gosh no but escarole are which are
Endive crops
um that are on the milder side and then
there's kind of the there's the kyoja
which are like the round softball red
radicchios that you see in the grocery
store or in the salad mixes those are
kind of like less bitter in the middle
and then you can go all the way down and
there's some really wacky ones that are
like um puntarelle is an is a it's like
basically you're you're harvesting the
flower stock so it's real bitter real
tough but then you soak it in the cold
water and it Mellows it out
um so so bitterness is kind of the key
there is the main feature but there's
it's you know it's kind of hard to
describe the flavor unless you you have
it and then the
um these forcing varieties because
they're just using they're not using
photosynthesis for their they're just
using cellular respiration so there's a
whole different metabolic pathway that's
happening within the plant
um and so it's just they're they're
different
um
chemical compounds that are being formed
within the leaves so it's um the
sweetness is like it's less bitter more
sweet but it's not like sugary sweet
it's kind of it's a it's a
yeah it's it's hard to describe but did
the crop find you or you found the crop
I guess what I mean by that is like did
you imagine yourself when you embarked
on farming like yeah endives it's gonna
be all about endives or like no no it
was this was not at all on my radar at
all I mean it's
um I've always enjoyed Radicchio but but
even you know prior to getting into
growing it myself you know it was not a
like it was a staple on my dinner table
as a Scandinavian Heritage person from
Minnesota you know
um it's not a not a part of my culinary
background but
um
so it was definitely working with the
restaurants that has has kind of pushed
us to broaden
um our our scope of the crops that we
grow
um you know every once in a while we
sneak Radicchio into our CSA but it it
doesn't usually go over super well uh
it's not a it's not a universally loved
thing like uh potatoes or tomatoes or
anything like that you trim the leaves
and then you have these leftover Roots
um what do you do with those
yeah so
um right now they're just going the
compost
um but I think that you know again being
that they are
um historically have been a forage crop
um there's some value for I was just
reading before this uh meeting that
historically they were used as a
substitute for oats for horses because
there's a similar kind of nutrient
breakdown
um so for sure you know if you had
Livestock on the farm through the winter
uh when these spent Roots could you know
just go into the pig pasture or into the
you know
parlor or horse barn whatever
um I think that's actually how these
first got discovered they would dig them
up and then stick them in the corner of
a barn
and then in the spring when things
started warming up they'd start to
sprout or if like water was Dripping on
them
they'd start to sprout and grow
um but in the darkness of the back
corner of the barn and so then you know
people as they're feeding horses or
whatever like snap one off and take a
bite it's like oh this is unique and
different roasted chicory is a coffee
substitute so I think you could talk to
coffee shops and see if that was
something that they wanted to
try getting locally
um it's showed up in
um Stouts and porters and from breweries
um so I think you could talk to Brewers
about so I do think that there's an
opportunity for turning that into an
additional Revenue stream as well and if
nothing else feeding it to livestock so
that you you know recapture that value
can you use the route more than once
they're um there's some speculation that
yes you could
um I I read some in our initial research
I read some
um
sources that said yes you can I think
maybe if you were to it the the tricky
part is like how you were would Harvest
that chicken because then if if you cut
it low enough to keep it as a nice tight
that doesn't just like all the all the
um leaves fall off
uh you're gonna cut it low enough that
you're gonna damage that that Central
growth tip
um
so I think you know maybe snapping it
off you could
um but it's not something that we
explored
it's interesting it's beautiful it's
like lots of sequencing and just like I
thank you for taking through that taking
us through that whole process and for
other Farmers as well just like and I
can just feel your joy in this discovery
yeah I mean right exactly and it's you
know again I I think that you know for
small scale agriculture
um
you know especially working with
restaurants a lot of the farmers that we
know that are you know growing mixed
vegetables in the winter they switch to
like large volumes of a couple root
crops
um you know selling to school districts
or uh wholesalers or grocery stores that
kind of thing which you know is
certainly
viable and um but you know we as threat
as the farm that we are we're we're
sized a little different and we found
that every time we try to dip our toe
into that really larger scale like
moving pallets of things at a time uh
and always you know we're just not
geared for that so we
we were really hoping that this would be
something that would allow us to kind of
keep that smaller scale but just you
know increase the value of those smaller
smaller deliveries to restaurants in the
winter and
um and it really did pay off
[Music]
foreign